un message clair inscrit sur le torse no
culture no future pour dénoncer
l'inaction politique concernant le monde
de la culture
c'était le 15 mai dernier rue neuve à
bruxelles l'une des artères commerçantes
les plus connus de la capitale belge
quentin chavériat comédien metteur en
scène et performeurs décide à l'occasion
du déconfinement de dénoncer l'abandon
du secteur culturel en réalisant une
performance torse nu une performance
rapidement interrompues par la police
locale qui demande au jeune homme de se
rhabiller immédiatement quentin
chavériat s'exécute
évidemment nous nous attendions à ce que
la performance soit arrêté par la police
donc là nous avons tenu une dix minutes
et donc de fait la police nous arrêtent
et cherchent un prétexte en fait parce
que pour eux il sentait que quelque
chose ne devait pas se passer sans aulas
qui devait l'arrêter mais ne savait pas
pourquoi
le premier prétexte pour me donne c'est
l'attentât à la pudeur parce que je suis
torse mais je dis ah bon on a on n'a pas
le droit mais il ya un message politique
marquée sur le torse les déjà là ils se
disent ah ça ça peut être dangereux
deux mois plus tard lui et ses acolytes
reçoivent une amende de 250 euros chacun
mentionnant une interdiction de circuler
après avoir déposé un recours contre
l'amendé
quentin chavériat vient d'apprendre que
celui ci a été refusée mais ils estiment
que ce n'est pas à lui de payer mais
bien à l'état nous recevons en courrier
qui nous informe que notre contestation
n'est pas reçue par ce qu'il considère
que nous n'étions pas sur la rue neuve
pour les raisons pour lesquelles nous
devions y être c'est à dire pour faire
des achats ou faire du shopping pour se
rendre dans les magasins nous étions sur
la rue neuve pour porter un message
politique
et ça c'est émotif à 250 euros damende
par personne
aujourd'hui quentin chavériat ne compte
pas s'arrêter là et se dit prêt à aller
en justice pour se défendre et défendre
les droits de la culture dans un
contexte épidémique